nach einem jahr corona wirtz leider noch
mal richtig spannend und die rechnung
ist so einfach wie deprimiert mutante -
test strategie plus schneckentempo beim
impfen gleich exponentielles wachstum
schreiben sie das nicht fragt was morgen
ab was diesem land fehlt meiner meinung
nach ist vision orientierung im grunde
laptop nennen die amerikaner lassen wenn
die formulierung nicht so verbrannt wäre
würde ich sagen ein hauch von wir
schaffen das was ist denn das ziel der
plan für die nächsten wochen kann mir da
mal jemanden mut machen
wir versuchen jetzt die brücken zu bauen
aber wir wissen auch nicht wohin werden
die genauer bauen also das ufer sehen
wir ja auch nicht das ist ja überhaupt
dass das ganz schwieriger an einer
pandemie kleiner tipp wenn ich keine
ahnung habe wo das ufer ist dann baue
ich vielleicht keine brücke sondern
erstmal ein boot dritte welle da und
trotzdem locker
so ist jetzt halt die stimmung im land
wir erklären quasi corona für beendet
in nordrhein westfalen zum beispiel
öffnet armin laschet nächste woche
wieder alle schulen und brandenburg hat
bei der sogenannten notbremse gleich
wieder die notbremse gezogen
die gilt bei denen jetzt doch erst ab
incident 200 meine klar man freut sich
für jeden einzelhändler ist ja logisch
sogar zoos haben wieder auf in karlsruhe
zum beispiel wo während des lok bei uns
immerhin opernsänger reingelassen worden
warum auch immer
also wenn das nicht mal eine einstimmung
auf das ende des zu lockdown sys
schimpanse belly ganz verzückt
schimpanse benny versucht sich
aufzuhängen im hintergrund sieht das
denn keiner
aber ja gut gemeint mal gucken wie lange
noch gelockert wird
die meisten läden lassen ja moment die
kunden nur nach dem klick and meet
system rein dann muss ich mir vor dem
shoppen einen slot buchen und hab dann
den laden in der zeit fast für mich
alleine
das ist eine super idee deswegen machen
wir das jetzt auch und den exklusiven
platz im studio gebucht hat diese woche
dieser zuschauer lutz wegener ja seit
monaten fiebert er nur auf diesen tag
hin lieber lotz herzlich willkommen bei
der heute show
was ist das denn hier garnicht let's
dance let's dance ist nebenan ist kein
problem wir haben ein riesen warteliste
kommt direkt der nächste verein dann
nicht so meine damen und herren impfen
zieht sich die hausärzte würden gern
mithelfen dürfen aber noch nicht
mithelfen weil weil sie auch nicht aber
dafür geht es endlich voran beim testen
die selbsttests für zu hause sind
endlich da die wo man nur noch im
vorderen nasenbereich rum rühren muss
und jeder deutsche darf sich ab sofort
ein mal pro woche kostenlos von einer
fachkraft testen lassen
wie läuft das so teilweise sind die
tests noch nicht geliefert oder es
scheitern an den räumlichkeiten wir
brauchen abgetrennte bereiche wo die
kunden separat getrennt von anderen
kunden eingeführt werden können deswegen
bieten nur zehn prozent von ihnen die
schnelltests überhaupt an
doch müssen kunden die 30 euro gebühr
vorstrecken und wir wissen einfach nicht
wie wir es abrechnen sollen bitte
verzeihen sie mir ich kann ihnen auf
jeden fall sagen heute nicht passt sehr
gut heute kann ich gar nicht
wir haben immer noch keine tests
strategie das jetzt es bei aldi
rumliegen ist ja noch keine strategie
und was sagt das bitte über eine
regierung wenn aldi und lidl sowie
schneller organisiert kriegen als der
staat hier idee sollen die discount hat
doch alles übernehmen was der staat
sonst macht machen die jetzt auch ja bei
lidl am pfandautomaten kann zum beispiel
neuerdings eine steuererklärung abgeben
und der fleischerei fachverkäufer bei
edeka darf traum durchführen
entscheidungen gibt es nebenan beim käse
oder zeugnisse die kanzlerin kasse zwei
abholen entweder das sogenannte all die
tour oder die mittlere reife strategie
wäre ja bevor ich schulen und läden
aufmachen genug tests einkaufen und
klären wer die bezahlt ist noch völlig
vom board das bund oder länder machen
aber solange die teile rund fünf euro
kosten muss der staat sich schon kümmern
kann sich halt nicht jeder leisten
funktionierende corona im test strategie
impfen
das wäre so die staatliche to do liste
warum muss man denn in deutschland immer
darüber diskutieren warum muss dann
alles der staat anbieten
das muss doch nicht alles der bund oder
auch nicht mehr die länder und detail
regeln das wird sich doch ergeben
ebenso was ergibt sich oder halt nicht
ja ich habe das gefühl ihr habt euch
ergeben
vielleicht sind es aber auch völlig
ausgelastet inzwischen mit dem krisen
management in der sogenannten masken
affäre ja mindestens zwei
unionspolitiker haben fette provisionen
für die vermittlung von masken kassiert
drei weiteren wird vorgeworfen gegen
geld für aserbaidschan lobby ihr zu
haben
in der union herrscht jetzt nackte panik
vor der wahl am sonntag ist nicht
übertrieben
zum beispiel wegen nikolas löbel der
250.000 euro vermittlungsgebühr für zwei
drei telefonate marktgerecht findet aber
wie hat er selber mal so treffend gesagt
politik muss dabei immer so verdammt
perfekt sein
dabei ist politik einfach nur menschlich
denn politik wird von menschen gemacht
richtig von menschen die geld mögen es
ist wirklich tragisch mal nicht ganz
ernst die große masse der abgeordneten
im bundestag verhält sich natürlich
korrekt und macht einen super job
jetzt stecken sie alle zusammen im die
da oben sack nicht zuletzt dank georg
nüßlein von der csu während der löbel
immerhin sein mandat niedergelegt hat
will das nüßlein hier die legislatur
noch beenden pensionsansprüche
schade eigentlich gibt es dagegen nicht
was von ratiopharm
kennen sie das auch
sie sind ein mann im mittleren alter und
können nicht mehr richtig zurücktreten
das muss nicht sein wir empfehlen gehe
jetzt forte stärkt die reste ihres moral
empfindens und wäre es rein pflanzlich
mag bis dato fink macht den abschied
leichter und für ganz hartnäckige fälle
von folter gen zäpfchen hinten rein und
raus aus dem bundestag zur riesigen
nebeneinkünften fragen sie ihren anwalt
oder steuerberater gute preise gute
besserung
tatsächlich eignen sich die herren
nüßlein und löbel aber auch ganz
hervorragend als bösewichte um von
strukturellen problemen der union
abzulenken
cdu und csu haben doch jahrelang
erfolgreich gegen eine lobby register
gekämpft und jetzt sind so voll wird und
auf nüßlein und löbel dieser rasse
also erstmal ist das alles so ein
fürchterlicher vorgang er zunächst mal
ist es ein ärgernis
sowas macht man nicht so ein verhalten
ist unanständig und es beschämt uns ein
solches verhalten widerspricht
fundamental unseren grundwerten wer sich
daran persönlich bereichert der ist kein
volksvertreter und der muss das
parlament auch schleunigst verlassen den
lacken hatte ich fast vergessen
philipp man kann nicht mieten am tor am
letzten wochenende trotz eigenem lobby
skandal zum cdu-spitzenkandidaten für
meck pomm gewählt glückwunsch
ausdrücklich unterstützt übrigens von
parteichef armin laschet der in der
maske affäre aber einen auf große
aufräumer macht extrem glaubwürdig meine
wegen cdu und csu gibt es im lobby
register entwurf eben keinen exekutiven
fußabdruck mit dem man erkennen könnte
welche interessenvertreter im
gesetzgebungsprozess was durchgesetzt
ja zuviel transparenz geht halt auch ein
stückweit gegen die cdu tradition
tja macht mal genauso weiter freunde
aber dann beschwert euch auch nicht über
noch mehr politikverdrossenheit
keine frage die union hat jetzt ein
image problem
gucken sie mal was im internet schon
angeboten wird liebe den trauben werde
jetzt abgeordneter bei cdu oder csu
gecoacht von erfolgsunternehmer prinz
marcus von anhalt buchende holte seinen
crash kurs volksvertreter in fünf
minuten mindestens cdu csu
unser motto
[Musik]
mann mann mann mann mann jetzt also auch
noch korruption so schrecklich was wir
deutschen in diesen tagen alles über uns
selbst neues lernen wir schalten wir
live zur passenden feierstunde ins
schloss bellevue zu gernot hassknecht
meine damen und herren liebe mitbürger
frank-walter alte säge danke dass wir da
einen plattenbau heute für diese
feierstunde nutzen dürfen
leider es ist kein schöner anlass
ich entziehe hier mit der bundesrepublik
deutschland wegen anhaltenden versagens
in der korona krise sämtliche gütesiegel
made in germany nichts mehr wert
organisations und effizienz weltmeister
das war einmal
sogar meine siegerurkunde von den
bundesjugendspielen 65 ungültig wir
können nichts mehr
ich schau als deutscher in den spiegel
und bin sogar noch enttäuscht als sonst
ja da brauchst du gar nicht so traurig
zu gucken frankie die ganze welt lacht
sich doch inzwischen kaputt bei uns gar
natürlich nicht die eigentlich wie wo
anders läuft in kalifornien zum beispiel
sie haben ihre impfung schon erhalten
der zoo von san diego hat inzwischen
neuen menschenaffen mit einem
experimentellen corona wachsen geimpft
sei völlig aus und was haben wir immer
gelästert über schlecht organisierte
griechen und so jetzt sind wir selber
griechen ausgerechnet in der schwersten
krise sei im krieg ist hier jeder
zuständig und gleichzeitig keiner
diese woche wurden schon wieder corona
hilfen auf eis gelegt weil der staat
sich hat beißen lassen
dabei hat peter altmaier doch neulich
noch hoffnung gemacht
das heißt es kommt schwung in den
geschichte und das ist auch dringend
notwendig weil die betroffenen auf das
geld dringend angewiesen sind wirklich
bitter meinst du die
schon mitte märz auf die komplette
november hilfe angewiesen
du bist da einer großen sache auf der
spur
wir können nichts mehr und machen die
selben fehler immer wieder genau wie
beim impfen werden natürlich zu wenig
tests zu spät bestellt alles kommt zu
spät wirklich das einzige was wir immer
noch drauf haben ist comedy der
legendäre deutsche humor ich finde
dringlichkeit hilft im leben und im
miteinander und auch solche dinge in der
schule zu vermitteln
das gehört doch mit dazu immerhin zum
spenden überpünktlich der lockdown
kostet jede woche fantastilliarden aber
hier streiten bund und länder wie er die
verfügten schnelltests bezahlt wie blöd
sind ja eigentlich welches bild von
deutschland soll denn am ende bleiben
das war übrigens jogi löw als er
beschlossen hat in rente zu gehen so und
zum abschluss dieser deprimierenden kag
veranstaltung spielt das peter hartz
trio noch die nationalhymne
ich kann es nicht ändern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken märz gut los los du
scheiße fährt